the Apple watch finally gets into
customers hands tomorrow some customers
a lot more will have to wait a key to
this watch the success will be the
quality of the apps being developed for
it Mike Weir's is head of operations for
App Store a company that helps create
mobile apps Mike is app development for
the watch going to be much different
from app development for the iPhone or
the iPad yeah it actually is very
different in a number of ways you can
look at it from the business perspective
of just the user experience that you're
going to have to deliver is different
it's on someone's wrist so the way we
look at that is that you have about a
seven-second difference where someone
can twitch their wrists and look at
something quickly or pull out their
phone and get a different experience so
what you want to put on that device has
to be incredibly timely and meet that
requirement of something that you need
in that short amount of time you don't
want also interrupt the person all day
long with them twisting their wrist so
there's a lot of things that you have to
think about from a user experience
perspective from a technical perspective
also when you're designing a nap there's
things that we really don't think too
much about when we're loading a new app
onto our iPhone for example what's the
power utilization going to be but when
you start thinking about a watch the
last thing you want to do is have an app
that's really not extremely well
designed for power control because then
you'll run out of power during the day
we've already heard about Apple
developed apps that don't exactly run
fast on the Apple watch how much of a
concern is that for a developer that the
processing power of the watch isn't up
to delivering the kind of experience
people are used to with consumer devices
now where it's pretty much instant on
yeah this is also another pretty
important area @absolut we actually
trained our developers who are working
on the watch on this tethered scenario
and what that really means is that most
of the processing is done on the iPhone
and then we just remote the user
experience down to the down to the watch
itself so that all you're getting is the
UI and the buttons that you're pressing
there's much processing as you can do on
the phone is what you really need to
leverage that kind of architecture most
developers don't know how to do that
though how much information are you
going to be putting on that little watch
I can barely read
my smartphone at this point when we were
spending so much to you knows this for
spending so much time looking at our
apps reading text now we're going to do
it even smaller how are you going to
deliver all that information in a way
that people can actually see it and see
it in the long term yeah that's a it's a
question that comes up and it really is
the best way to kind of think about it
is it's not just taking what you do on
an iPhone and putting it on a watch all
right if walk us through that cuz that's
how I see it yeah we can't see it yes
you can scroll and if she can do some
level of reading but the intention of
the watch and way the real opportunity
is delivering a different kind of
experience so for example the watch has
much more information about sensors that
are happening on your body so we're
working with one of our development
partners who's doing an appt with us
called sim 6 and they are looking at
integrating in sensor feedback from the
watch to the iphone and then being able
to do the work on the iphone and only
tell the person the information what
kind of information i'll give you a for
instance you're in the airport what's
the thing that we all have to look at
our ticket three or four times because
we forget what gate we're going to if
you get what flight number rat yes don't
need to see my entire itinerary I don't
need to see my frequent flyer points I
just want the little reminder its gate
42 so that's an example of how you have
to think about the scenario you're
looking to deliver and give just the
information that's relevant